So good morning. Um we have three more
classes. Uh the first class we are doing
today is on the nation state. Next
Tuesday we will do the Soviet Union. And
then the last class next Thursday will
be the American Empire. And that will do
it for the year. 60 classes. We've
covered the entire span of human
history. So um today we are doing the
nation state.
Nation state is composed of two words
nation and state. State is easy to
understand. It is just the supreme
executive authority sovereign to a
territory. The nation is a new idea and
it's the idea of a people with a shared
identity whether it's a language or a
culture or a history or ethnicity. Okay.
So um for example the Jews were for the
longest time a nation the state okay it
was only uh until the founding of Israel
that the Jews had a nation state uh
today uh there are many peoples
including the Kurds who are a people
living in the Middle East they are a
nation but they don't have a state okay
and this idea of the nation state um it
is probably the most powerful ideology
in human history. Um, it has led people
to tremendous achievements, but it's
also led people to catastrophic wars,
including World War I and World War II.
All right. All right. So, first thing I
want to do is go over where this idea
comes from. And in many ways it is the
culmination of
um different religious, economic and
social cultural factors. Okay. So let's
look at them individually.
Religion. All right. Um so as we
discussed last class with the Protestant
Reformation there is now a crisis of
faith because Christianity creates the
idea of the individual. The individual
is in direct connection with God. Before
the church would mediate this
connection. So you didn't have to worry
about God. You just have to worry about
the church. If you did what the church
told you, you could be promised entry
into heaven. The prot reformation
removes the Catholic Church from the
equation. Now you are in direct commune
with God and you must show absolute
faith if you are to achieve um
salvation. Okay. And so this creates a
crisis of faith because as an
individual how do you know you truly
believe in God? You know you love your
mothers but do you love your mother
every single day all the time? Probably
not. Okay. But um in religion you cannot
doubt God ever. You can never you can
never throw a t temper tantrum at God or
you will be sent to hell. So it creates
this conflict. Okay. Um and there are
diff and historically there have been
different solutions to this problem. So
the first solution that people have
proposed is the idea of money. Let's
just replace God with
money. Right? Right? And that gives us
the idea of
capitalism. Um the Calvinists believe
this, okay? That God is money, money is
God. And if you accumulate enough
wealth, then that shows your absolute
faith in God and God's love for you. All
right? Um so that's the idea of money.
Then people have said, "Nope, God is
reason." All right? So as long as you
pursue reason, as long as you show
enlightenment, then that shows your
faith in God. Okay? And this gives us
the idea of the
enlightenment. Sorry,
enlightenment as well as
liberalism.
Right? Then others have said, "Nope, God
is the individual itself.
Okay. So, as long as you believe in
yourself, as long as you engage in a
process of self-discovery and
self-growth, then that will lead you
into heaven. And this was most famous
famous famously proposed and we
discussed this last class by
Freud and Yun. And this has become the
basis for what we call modernism, right?
which is still with
us
today.
Um and then there's proposed another
solution to this problem and it's the
idea that God is in the
nation. All right? And it turns out that
of all these ideas, the most powerful,
the most resilient, the most enduring is
this
idea that by celebrating your nation,
you are celebrating your faith in God.
Why? Because the other solutions propose
a problem. And it and the problem
um it creates is the individual is still
isolated from others. Okay. It still
creates a problem of
alienation and the nation solves this
problem right because a nation has to be
by definition a community of individuals
with a shared
identity.
So the
nation is the perfect solution because
it both um solves the problem of
religion and it solves a problem of
politics and community. In fact the
nation is a conflation of both religion
and politics. Okay? And that's why
historically it has been the most
emotionally emotionally uh the most
powerful idea. Right? Does that make
sense? All right. So from a religious
purpose
uh the nation state solves the problem
of faith and
alienation. All right. Now let's look at
economics. So during this time you have
the industrial
revolution and there are many issues
created by the industrial revolution.
Um the first problem
is you need to constantly expand because
you need markets and resources right. So
expansion another saying this is that
you need to engage in
imperialism. Another problem created by
the problem of the industrial revolution
is the rise of the boujo
z. Bjo.
Um, historically it was the priests and
the warriors who were the elite of
society. But now with the industrial
revolution, the boujo, the
industrialists and the capitalists are
now the new elite. And as such they
obviously want more political
power but they all but what they really
want is
um property
rights, right? They want to be assured
that the wealth they've generated can be
protected and inherited by their
children and their grandchildren and
great great grandchildren. Now the
problem is this. The problem is uh the
system of the
monarchy cannot really ensure property
rights and the reason why is the king
can be overthrown. Okay, their stocky
can be overthrown and this is what
happens throughout European
history but the nation state cannot be
overthrown. Right? Does that make sense?
So the nation state is a
solution to the problem of property
rights for the partial
Z. Also the nation state has the
resources to engage in
imperialism and it has the desire to
engage in imperialism. Monarchies are
usually pretty conservative. They like
to maintain their position and they will
form alliances in order to maintain
their uh position. The nation state is
aggressive and expansionist and
imperilous. Okay, does that make sense?
So from an e economic perspective u the
nation state solves a problem created by
the industrial
revolution. Okay, so that's the economic
factor. Then let's look at
the social cultural factor.
social cultural aspect of this of this.
So what's happening because of the
industrial revolution is that people are
moving from the
towns. Oh, sorry I said this wrong.
People are moving from the
villages to the cities. Okay, you have
this massive process of
urbanization also because in the
revolution there's more trade. There's
now the market, right? So these goods
are proliferating throughout the entire
country. Okay? Okay. And this creates
the idea of
systemization and
standardization and you have mobility of
people, of goods and of ideas. The
mobility and then you have new
technology, right?
not just uh in factories and not just in
like steamships but also in print and it
spreads
literacy and
information.
So think of this as just the beginning
of globalization right in China we're
inu inuluated with uh new ideas all the
time because of the internet because of
access to the world but for people for
most people this can be um frustrating
and bewildering and it creates
psychological issues okay primarily uh
the idea of
enemy enemy just means means
um a loss of sense of cultural
rootedness, right? Um as things change,
you don't know how to adapt to the
change. Your values are based on the
past. You're not sure if your values can
confront the future. Okay. Also,
alienation. Alienation just means a
sense of power of
powerlessnesslessness. Okay. You lack
agency. These changes are happening. so
fast and so quickly you don't know if
you can control these changes.
Also
disenchantment disenchantment
disenchantment means all these changes
changes are
dehumanizing right you're becoming just
a and machine you're becoming no
more than a machine in today's world AI
could possibly replace us all right so
it's creating all this doubt all this
confusion and the nation
state okay so and there are different
solutions to is there's
communism, there's
liberalism, and then there's
nationalism. And for people, okay, all
three ideas are are appealing, but
u communism preaches the idea of
international solidarity, right? Which
can be for people even more confusing.
Liberalism preaches the idea of
individual rights. But if you're poor,
the right to speak, uh, the right to
organize does not really apply to you.
And the fact of the matter is that most
are poor. But
nationalism, okay, the fact that we are
one group of people in a struggle
against other groups of people, this is
powerful. Okay, this is appealing. Also,
if you think about it, nationalism can
absorb other ideas, right? You can be
both a nationalist and a liberal. And in
fact, most people were. You can also be
a nationalist and a communist which was
what Joseph Salen proposed right and
this is what mon proposed. So
nationalism is the one ideology that can
absorb and control all other ide
ideologies. Okay does that make sense?
So for these three particular reasons
religious
transformation economic transformation
and social cultural transformation the
nation state became the best idea of
that time and it spread really quickly.
Okay. All right. So, let's talk about
widespread. Okay. To understand
widespread so quickly, let's talk about
game
theory. Game theory. So, let's imagine
let's do a thought experiment and say
there are millions of us playing a game.
It doesn't matter what game we're
playing. Okay? It could be like
checkers, it could be chess, it could be
monopoly, it could be game of tag, it
doesn't matter. But, there are millions
of us individually playing this game.
We're all individual players. The
problem is this. The problem is that if
maybe a group of us, maybe three or four
or five, they decide that they will
coordinate. They're going to get they're
going to play the game together. Maybe
because they're family, maybe because
your friends, it doesn't matter why, but
the moment they decide to play as a
group, this automatically forces
everyone else to group together. Okay?
And that's the idea of the nation state.
The moment that France decide we're a
nation state, that forces everyone else,
Germany, Russia, Italy to become nation
states as as well because otherwise
you're going to lose this game. Right?
The other thing that's really important
for us to remember about this theory is
this. To win this game now, as an Asian
state, it does not actually matter your
size. What matters is
your
cohesion. How well you're willing to
work together to to play to play this
game, right? Or maybe unity of
will. So, for
example, maybe there's a bar fight
between four brothers and 10 strangers.
Well, I would bet the four brothers are
more likely to win than the 10
strangers, right? because the 10
strangers don't really know each other.
They don't really care. There's not much
at stake here. But the four brothers
need to protect each other, okay? And
they love each other. And so they're
going to fight a lot harder. They're
going to fight to the death. Whereas the
10 strangers, if they feel uh they're
going to lose, they're going to run
away. Okay? So that's the idea of the
nation state. What determines the
strength of the nation state is unit of
will, cohesion, not size, not wealth,
not territory. Okay? That's really
important to remember. Does that make
sense?
Okay. So, um the idea of a nation state
comes from two different sources. The
first is the
enlightenment. Okay. The second is
romanticism. Okay. So to summarize to
recap the enlightenment is this major
intellectual trend happening in 17th and
18th and 19th century Europe at this
time right the spread of reason as a god
the spread of science of literacy of
three thinking of
debate right romanticism is something we
didn't really talk that much about but
romantism is a direct direct
response to the problems created by
romantis oh sorry by by by the
enlightenment Because Enlightenment
preaches the idea of
science of
um social forces
um of an idea called theism which is God
has um set the rules of the game. He's
left us and we're free to play the game.
And this creates a lot of anxiety in
people. So romantics were a movement to
respond to the problems created by
enlightenment. Um so they focus more on
nature rather than
science. Okay. They believe that um
there's a divine power to nature that we
can access by embracing it. They
believed in the idea of individual will
to change the course of history that the
individual that we are stronger than the
historical social forces um around us.
Okay. And they rejected uh
materialism. They they were they were
very spiritual. Okay. Now the romantics
are a huge movement of people. Have you
studied this before? Okay. So I don't
want to generalize too much. Okay. But
the romantics were a response to the
enlightenment thinkers. Okay. So from
the enlightenment um we have uh
Rouso and Rouso sorry I'm saying his
name wrong. Russo remember wrote a book
called the called the social contract
and in the book he argued that as
individuals we are born free with
inelible rights like the right to uh uh
life and liberty. We choose to surrender
some of these rights in order for more
safety and security and wealth
possibilities. Okay. Um
so the
people come together and it creates
something called the general
will which is the collective mind of the
people. Okay. And from the general will
you will have the
government but the government exists in
order to serve the general will which
serves the people. Okay? Does that make
sense? The government exists in order to
protect the indivual individual rights
of people to ensure their happiness to
ensure their well-being. This this is
where Abra Abraham Lincoln gets a famous
phrase of the
people by the people for the people.
Okay, he is just re
reiterating the idea of rousole. Okay,
and this of course is um implemented by
the French Revolution, right?
Napoleon and the
French French
France. Okay. And the general will
becomes manifest in the nation
state. Does that make sense? Okay. So
Russo proposed the idea and actually
discussed the French Revolution
implements this idea and gives us the
first iteration of the nation state. Now
this is really successful because what
it does is it conceives of a country as
a unified whole almost like as a body.
This is new in human history because
before in a monarchy the monarch the
people in the military were all
separate. Okay. In fact it was very
common at the time for monarchs to hire
foreign mercenaries
um to fight their wars. the people
weren't really engaged in war. But now
that in the French Revolution, when you
conceive the nation, the country as in
fact whole, you can now draw on the
people to become your soldiers. And in
fact, when you do this, you can create
almost an infinite supply of soldiers.
And because the people believe that
they're fighting for themselves, they're
more motivated, they're more energetic,
they're more willing to sacrifice
themselves than for mercenaries who are
just in it for the money. And that's why
the French Revolution was able to spread
throughout Europe and basically conquer
Europe including Spain, Italy and
Germany. Okay. But once the French
conquered most of Europe, it now stirs
resentment against the French because
before these were free and independent
uh people who had control over local
matters and now the French were coming
and imposing a new political, economic
and social regime on them and there were
foreign troops, French troops to make
sure that you had to obey. Okay. So this
creates a lot of resentment and the
people's response was to create their
own form of nationalism but in response
to French nationalism. Okay. So now
they're being influenced by
romanticism. And in romantism
um their response is is
this there is a
culture. Okay. And it gives us a
people. Okay. So from the beginning
there are no individuals. There's only a
culture and so it creates a community
and the people their responsibility is
to protect their culture to enhance the
culture to spread the culture and the
best way to do this is through the
nation state. Okay. So this gives us a
different
interpretation of the nation state and
because the French are now imposing
their culture on our indigenous culture
then we have responsibility as a people
to rebel and fight back. All right and
this will give
us German
nationalism. So it's the Germans who
first proposed this idea but then it
spreads to Italy as well. Okay. So these
are two extremely different
interpretations of nationalism. In the
French interpretation which is also
supported by the Americans and the
British, the nation exists to protect
individual rights. In a second
interpretation, a romantic German
interpretation, the nation state exists
in order to protect a culture. Okay?
Because it's culture that gives life to
people. Okay? Okay. What what the
Germans will say is the culture is
something that you don't think of. It's
already in your
blood. Right? Does that make sense?
Okay. So, um that's the general
introduction. Are any questions before I
move on to specific examples and
evidence? Okay.
Great. Um so, we're going to summarize
and look at the origins of the uh nation
state.
Okay. All right. So really important is
to understand the nation state replaces
the monarchy. Okay. And there are three
fundamental differences that I want you
to remember and emphasize. The first is
for the monarchy uh the bureaucracy is
ultimate authority. Why? Because the
bureaucracy is what represents the
monarch right? But in nation state it's
the people or the culture. In a
monarchy, the elite are the aristocracy,
those that have been rewarded um by the
monarch. But in a nation state, it's
usually the bourgeozi that are the
elite. Okay? The industrialists, the
capitalists. Um the monarchy
um it's pretty flexible. It's because it
is really about shifting alliances,
right? Monarchs cooperate with other
monarchs to maintain the peace and to
prevent um other monarchs from
encroaching on their territory. And as a
result the monarchs tend to be
conservative people. They like the way
things as they
are and they work towards that. Okay. So
um after French revolution there was
something called the commerce of Vienna
in 1815 where the monarchs of Europe
basically decided to never fight again.
And this was a successful model until
1848 when the people rebelled against
them. Okay. Um and but the nation stayed
because it is almost like a new
religion. It wants standardization and
systemization. It wants everyone to buy
into the nation state and as a result
it's expensive. It's it's either
expensive outwards or it's in expensive
inwards. Okay. Um does that make sense
guys? All
right. All right. Um so let's look at
some evidence or support for uh this
argument. So this is a really good book
called Seeing Like a State by James
Scott published by Yale University uh
press. Fantastic book. Okay, if you if
you are interested in this stuff, I
highly recommend you read this book. And
he explains how uh the nation say comes
about because of process of
systemization andization created by all
the social forces happening in Europe at
this time. Okay, so let's just read
quickly what he wrote. Three factors in
the end conspired to make what Kula
calls the metrical revolution possible.
Okay. So the fact that we use the meter
uh that is came about during this time.
First the growth of market exchange
encouraged uniformity in measures. So
capitalism. Second both popular
sentiment and enlightenment philosophy
favored a single standard throughout
France. Okay. Enlightenment. Finally the
revolution and especially Napoleon uh
the the Napoleonic state building
actually enforced the metric system in
France and the empire. Okay. Okay. So
just summarizing what we dis discussed
in the first
section and then Scott um summarizes the
homogeneization of measures then was
part of a larger immenstory
simplification. At one stroke the
equality of all French people before the
law was guaranteed by the state. They
were no longer mere subjects of the
lords and sovereign but bearsers of
alienable rights as citizens. Okay. So
this is just repeating what I just said
which is the main purpose of the French
Revolution was create a nation state
that guaranteed individual
rights. All right. Um this is imagine
communities by Benedict Anderson and
again he goes into uh why the nation
state was born and how it spread and he
explains what made the new communities
imaginable was a half aous but explosive
interaction between a system of
production and productive relations
capitalism technology of communications
print and the fatality of human
linguistic diversity. Okay. So what he
means by that is that at Europe at this
time there really is no conception of
the idea of a national language.
Everyone just spoke what was local to
them. There's also no conception of
race. Okay, we we discussed this. Race
is a really new concept that is that is
that is that was alien to most people.
Okay. But now that you have print,
you're able to spread language and
you're able to create a national
language. And this is key to the nation
state because print and language allows
people to think the same way and to
imagine a shared history, right? Because
culture, it's all just made up. History,
it's all just made up. There's nothing
real in it. Okay? And because of this
it's destroyed uh linguistic diversity.
So if you were to go to France in the
year 1800 uh and you go from v village
to village they would to they would
speak different languages.
Right? All right.
Um uh this is too long to read okay but
I'll just summarize. And what what he
says is this. Um before the nation
state, the elite of Europe, the way they
um communicate with each other is
through inter marriage. Okay. And as a
result, there really wasn't an like a
sense of national
identity. But now with the rise of print
technology,
um there's now a separation, right?
Because you spoke your own language. And
this is important because um the boujo
are the new elite and in theory they
would want to move their capital around
Europe. Um they they want they would
want to move to places where the capital
would be more safe, where it be most
productive, right? But the idea of a
national language prevents them from
doing that. Okay, does that make sense?
Great. All right. Um John Rouso we
talked about we're just going to read a
couple sentences from this the his book
of social contract. Each of us puts his
his person and all his power in common
under certain direction of the general
will in our corporate capacity. We
receive each member as an indivisible
part of the whole.
Okay. Uh but I'm wrong to speak of a
Christian republic. Those two terms are
mutually exclusive. Christianity
preaches only servitude and dependence.
Its spirit is so favorable to tyranny
that it always profits by such a re
regime. German Christians are made to be
slaves and they know it and don't mind
much. This short life counts for too
little in their eyes. Okay, so this is
the theory of the separation of church
and
state. All right, this this is the
beginning of the idea of separation of
church and state. It's one of the
fundamental ideas of the French
Republic. And that's why in today
there's so much antagonism between um
Islamists and the government. Okay?
Because the Islamists want to maintain
their tradition. They want to wear the
hijab. They they want to maintain their
cultural customs. Uh but the French
nation prevents them from doing so in
public places and in schools. Okay.
Um so as we discussed Napoleon will
spread
uh French enlightenment principles
throughout Europe. 1805 he defeats both
the Russians and the Austrians at the
battle of Oculates. And at this point
Napoleon should be made Holy Roman
Emperor. Okay? He should be made emperor
of the Holy Roman Empire as is
tradition. But the emperor at that time
uh decides you know what rather than
give up the throne to Napoleon I'm just
going to dissolve this confederation the
empire and this was a major blow to um
to to these people okay because the
empire in in their minds existed for a
thousand years okay ever since
Charlemagne and the Holy Roman Empire is
direct here to the Roman Empire okay so
for a lot of these intellectuals living
in the Holy Roman Empire this was
extremely embarrassing
um the Napoleon will create something
called the confederation or the rine
which replaces the Holy Roman Empire and
it's basically a vassel state to the
French. Okay. And this will antagonize
uh a lot of the Germans because they
feel as though their culture their
history it is being eroded. But at this
time this is really important the
Germans don't have a sense of
Germanness. They don't really have a
sense of a national identity. So what
will happen is to counter the French uh
German intellectuals will attempt to
create a new uh German national
identity. Okay, this is Ern's art. He's
a poet. Okay, and he believes that this
new identity should be fashioned like
this. Let the animy of your hearts be
your church. Okay, let us be one people
and let this nation be your religion.
Let hatred of the French be your
religion. Let freedom and fatherland be
your saints to whom you pray. All right.
So he's considered the father of German
nationalism because he's presenting this
idea that we Germans must exist in
opposition to the French. Okay. And this
idea is going to drive a lot of the
catastrophes of of European history for
the next hundred
years. Uh this is Johan Ficte. He is a
student of Kant. He is a major
philosopher in his own right. He's
considered the founder of a German uh
idealism school. and he explains that
okay if we want to create a nation state
we we have to figure out how to do so
what unites us as as as a people and
it's not um history because we have
different histories and he decides
because he's a huge fan of Shakespeare
that this shared heritage will be one of
language okay we will speak one language
together and this language the German
language is what will define our culture
and our identity he writes description
and character ization in such a language
is itself a directly vital and sensuous
matter. Okay. So our cultural identity
our gist will be manifested in our
language. All right. So at this time
there's a tremendous explosion of um
German literature to spread the idea of
language.
Okay. He also explains that the nation
state the nation it is not just a
collection of people. Okay, let's read
this passage together because it's
really important. Let the component
parts of our higher spiritual life be
just as dried out and thus let the bands
or national unity also be just as torn
apart lying about in wild disorder
scattered and disarrayed as are the
bones of a sear. Let them be bleached
and dried out by many centuries of
storms, deluches and blazing sun. The
animating breath of the spiritual world
has not yet ceased to blow. It will also
take hold of our natural bodies in our
bones and join them together so that
they might gloriously exist in a new and
transferate life. Okay. So what he's
saying is the nation is not a collection
of individuals. What the nation is, it's
individuals who are transformed together
that creates a nation. A nation will
transform everyone.
Okay. All right. So let's just
summarize. So uh let's just summarize
the differences between enlightenment
and romantism because the enlightenment
is is what's going to drive the French
uh nationalism and romantism is what's
going to drive German nationalism. Okay.
Um it's science versus nature, reason
versus emotions, liberty versus will and
struggle. Okay? Does that make
sense? Through the struggle through our
struggle as a people, we can liberate
ourselves from a French and reforge
ourselves as a great nation.
All right. So, main difference between
French nationalism and German
nationalism. Okay. Separation of church
and state. For the Germans, the nation
is the is the church. Uh the French
believe in the general
will. What is in the best interest of
everyone? The Germans believe in the
gist. Okay? The spirit of your of your
people. Okay? Does that make sense?
Great. All right. So I'm going to use an
example to highlight the difference
between the French form of nationalism
and the German form of nationalism. And
it has to do with the Jewish question.
Okay. So there are lots of Jews
throughout Europe at this time. Uh
they're they're they're minorities in
these in these countries. And the
question is with the rise of the nation
state, what do you do about the Jews?
Okay. And their problem because the Jews
believe themselves as a nation. Okay.
They don't have a state, but they're a
nation. And the Jews have the Bible.
Okay. Okay, which gives them a shared
language, a shared um culture, a shared
history, right? So, how do you deal with
a people in your nation that are
explicitly not part of your uh culture
and they're very adamant about not being
part of your culture?
So
um the French okay there is
anti-semitism throughout Europe at this
time okay but the response to animism is
different in in different nations in
1894 there's something called the Drifus
affair okay the Drifus affair is this
man Alfred Drifus he is Jewish by
ancestry
uh but at this time a lot of um elite
Jews have already accatized assimilated
into the popular culture
And um in 1894 he was arrested and
accused of being a German spy. Alfred
Drifus was an officer in the French
military. Uh the problem is that um
French counter intelligence conducted a
short investigation and they quickly
found out that found out that this man
was not the spy. But the French military
didn't want to lose faith. Also there
were a lot of anti-semitic elements
within the French military. So rather
than just say, "You know what? We got
the wrong guy. We were wrong. Uh let's
forget about this." Their response was
to put this real spot on trial and
acquit him. It's like, "No, you no,
you're innocent." Even though the
evidence all suggests he's guilty, and
we're going to put Drifus uh and they
put Drifus in prison in a penal colony
far away for his entire life. Okay. And
so news of this leaks and this creates a
national controversy, right? And a man
named Elma Zola who was probably the
most famous writer uh in France at this
time, he writes in a newspaper article
called I Accuse, okay? I accuse the
French military of corruption, of
incompetence, of negligence. I accuse
the French state of corruption,
incompetence, negligence. Okay. And so
the question then is why are these
people so riled up about this one guy in
prison? And the answer is it has to do
with the French identity. Okay, at this
point in history there's this huge
conflict between French liberals who see
themselves as heres to the French
Revolution and monarchists. Okay. Who
want to get rid of revolutionary
elements for the for the liberals like
ML Zola the republic is about
maintaining the rights of all citizens
and if one citizen loses his right if
one citizen is mistreated by the justice
system then all citizens will be
mistreated by the justice system. Okay.
So even though even though Alfred
Drifers is a Jew, the French form first
and foremost as a French citizen, right?
Because the French nation exists to
protect the rights of all those who are
citizens of France. Okay, does that make
sense? That's why this was a huge deal
in France and it lasted for about 10
years. Um and of course the German
response uh to the Jewish question uh
was the Holocaust. Okay. So, these are
two different conceptions of
nationalism, the French and the German.
All right. Um, any questions before I
move
on? Okay. Is is is this clear? Great.
All
right. So, let's um continue on
uh the nation state. Okay.
So before 1848
um the nation state nationalism it was
contained in Europe because the
nationalism was actually a threat to the
monarchy right because nationalism would
uh reduce a lot of their powers. But in
1848, there are too many revolutions and
rebellions throughout Europe. And
monarchs at this point recognized that
they can't really hold back the tide of
social change. And so certain nations
like Germany start to embrace
nationalism as a way to contain uh these
social changes. Okay. Um once nation
state came into being they needed a
certain philosophy about culture and
this man Charles Thorin provides that in
the origin of species right he presents
a new theory
um of human develop that contradicts all
Christian teaching which is the idea of
evolution okay and so the idea of this
is that God has no design Okay. Uh we
are who we are by random chance through
the process of
evolution. And this will give birth to
the idea of something racism. Okay?
Because if it's true that God has no say
in how we develop. If it's true that we
dealt by chance then then we can also
extrapolate from this that well there's
certain people that must be inherently
superior to others right there are
certain people that must have evolved to
be more intellectual to to be more
scientific to be more brave and because
Europe at this time is the wealthiest
and strongest and most advanced part of
the world then we're going also reason
that Europeans must also be superior as
a people to everyone else, the Africans,
the Asians. Okay? Right? So, this
introduced the idea of racism. And this
is a really popular thing to do back
then. Um, one thing that they were
really interested in is is skull, right?
Because they figured out if they can
measure the skull, then they can make
generalizations about the different
brains of different cultures. and of and
of course the entire point of this
exercise was to prove that in fact
Europeans were
superior.
Okay, this also leads to the idea of
eugenics. This is um Francis Golton who
is a cousin of Charles Darwin and both
Charles Darwin and Francis Golton was
concerned about the gene pool right
because for Darwin evolution meant that
bad genes were systematically eliminated
from the system. But in a time of
improved sanitation of improved hospital
care then people who should have died
are living right and this is then this
is going to dilute the quality of your
gene pool. So um Francis Golton proposed
the idea of eugenics that a nation the
society should
systematically eliminate bad genes from
the gene pool in order to maintain its
purity. And there are three ways that
you can do this right. The first is you
can do force sterilization. So people
who might be handicapped or um they are
criminals, you sterilize them to prevent
them from reproducing. That's one
solution. Another solution is well
execution, right? Right? So if you're a
criminal or you are um physically
violent or or or if you are low IQ, then
we should just execute you to prevent
you from polluting the gene pool. And
the third solution is to limit
migration. Okay, limit immigration and
limit migration. And this is extremely
popular idea in United States, right?
Because at this time in in history, you
have all these um Europeans from low
genetic stock, the Polish, the Irish,
the Italians, the Eastern Europeans
coming into United States at this time.
And this was posing a real threat to the
Wasp
elite. Okay. And that's why in the
United States, this eugenics movement
really takes off. Okay. Really the
center of the eugenics movement in the
world at the end of 19th cent at the end
of 20th century. Sorry. At the end of
19th century, the beginning of 20th
century is really the United States.
Okay. There are many many states in the
United States that passed for
sterilization
laws. Um this is Madison Grant. He wrote
a very popular book about how there are
different
races and the Nordic race
um the
Germans, the Scandinavians and the
British, they are the dominant race.
They are the superior race. But over
time the numbers are diluting and
therefore
um the Nordic people must work together.
Okay. And guess who really enjoys his
idea who who was a big fan of Ma Madison
Grant Hitler, right? The Nazis uh will
translate his book and spread his book
and a lot of his ideas will become the
basis for Nazi eugenics policy, right?
And the Nazis were notorious for taking
the disabled
um the handicapped and basically uh
forcing them into gas chambers. Okay.
Um this is what he says. A rigid system
of selection through the elimination of
those who are weak or unfit would solve
the whole question in 100 years as well
as enable us to get rid of the
undesirabs who crowd our jails,
hospitals, and insane asylums. It's hard
for us to imagine, but in in the 1930s,
this is a really widespread idea in
America, in Britain, and in Germany.
Extremely widespread among the uh elite.
In fact, in 1935, if you ask me what was
most likely h like likely to happen,
then I would tell you that America,
Britain, and Germany would ally
themselves because they saw saw
themselves as one people and they
would attack the Soviet Union because
Soviet Union was a Slavic country that
was communist and both the Slavs and the
communists were a threat to the Nordic
people who are
capitalistic. Right? That's in 1935 that
was the most likely scenario. In fact,
there were a lot of people proposing
this
scenario. So why is it that it would be
America and Britain who would support
Soviet Union in destroying Germany?
Well, that's a question we will look at
next class. Okay? Because it's a huge
mystery why that happened when the when
when when in reality it should have been
America, Britain and Germany versus
Soviet Union. Okay. All right.
So um this now gives us the age of
imperialism. Uh the Europeans are now
need more resources but they're also
spreading their cultural mission to
civilize the entire world because they
are the master race, right? They have
the white men's burden to civilize all
others. Okay? Now they didn't go into um
Africa before because of malaria issues.
Okay. If you're European, you went into
Africa, you're going to die. But with
major advancements in uh medicine, they
now had um um they medicine against
malaria. Okay. And very quickly they
they basically carved up Africa amongst
themselves. They had a conference and
they decided which who would get who.
And their um imperialism in Africa was
notorious, right? It was is one one of
the worst atrocities in humanist history
especially in the Congo which was
controlled by Belgium. Basically the
king of Belgium Leopold had a mercenary
army go in enslave the people and
extract all the resources from uh the
Congo and it was his own personal
property his own personal state estate.
Okay. All
right. Um also China. Okay. So, China
was basically carved up by the
Europeans, right? The Americans
negotiated something called the open
door policy and everyone agreed to carve
China up into different sections. Okay?
We call these the treaty ports.
Right?
Now, the problem for the Europeans
though are the Japanese.
So when so in the European understanding
of the
world the Europeans are superior right
especially the northern people so
everyone else should submit and
surrender to the Europeans and that's
what happened in Africa and that's what
happened in China but not
Japan Japan underwent tremendous social
change called a major restoration to go
from a feudal
um society into a modern industrial
nation that in 1905 was able to defeat a
major European power, the Russians in a
war. Okay. And this was shocking because
this went against all
um all uh understanding of the world at
this time. Um what really surprised
people was the rapid pace of
transformation in Japan. It was as
though everyone decided that we as a
people needed to change and we're going
to change today. Okay? And that's and
that's what Japan did, right? So you
look at politics. Um in 1890 they will
establish basically the parliament and
by 1928 you had
universal male suffrage. Okay. Basically
1928 every man in Japan could
vote economically right the Japanese
economy exploded.
Um, if you go to Japan today, you'll be
amazed
by how well organized the society is.
Um, everyone, almost everyone in Japan
reverse parks. Okay, if you look at this
picture, maybe there's this one guy for
whatever reason who decides not to
reverse park, but everyone else reverse
parks. There's no law that says you must
reverse park. Everyone just does it
because of a sense of social
cohesion.
Okay. Um in the 13th century the Mongols
having conquered Korea and China and
most of Asia launched two invasions of
Japan which both both these invasions
fail. Now the myth is the kam kamicazi
right the divine wind which saved Japan
from the invasion. That's not true.
That's just part of Japanese mythology.
The real reason what really happened is
the Mongols were able to land forces
both times. But what they discovered was
they could not divide and conquer.
Usually the policy of an invader is to
find local allies, establish a beach
head on the island and then slowly
expand outwards. Okay, that's a policy.
But in Japan, the Mongols could not find
any local allies. The people were united
against the invaders and as a result it
became too expensive and too burdensome
for the Mongols to take over Japan.
Okay, does that make sense? And this is
and this creates the sense of national
identity and national unity that still
persists
today. All right, and that's why um I
just say this but the strongest nation
in East Asia is not China, it's Japan.
Okay. You have to look at social
cohesion. You have to look look at um
how willing people are willing
to fight and die for the nation. And uh
historically um the nation with the most
patriotism has always been Japan, not
China. Okay? So please keep this in
mind. All right. Um now we go into World
War I and World War II. In 1871, the
German Empire is proclaimed. Okay, the
Persians unite all um Germany into one
political entity and now they're a
threat to Britain because remember um
the British foreign policy is we must
always ensure a balance of power in
Europe. If one power arises, we must
fight it. Okay. So when uh Napoleon
arose uh Britain spent infinite amount
of money and resources to defeat
Napoleon which it which it ultimately
did. Okay. Now with Germany in power in
Europe, Britain is now going to
challenge it and ensure a balance of
power in Europe. Okay. Does that make
sense? At the same time, what's
happening is the spread of nationalism
throughout the former throughout the
Ottoman and AustriaHungary Empire.
Remember the Ottomans and the
AustriaHungary Empire are these
multithnic empires that don't really
have any reason to exist anymore in an
age of the nation state and of
nationalism. Okay. So, uh this is the
Ottoman Empire. They're based in
uh
um Istanbul. Okay. But but they also
occupy what we call the Balkans, Greece,
Macedonia,
um Montenegro, Serbia. Okay. So, the
Greeks rebel against the Ottomans and
they're successful in doing so in the
Greek war of independence.
Now uh we talk a lot of the Greeks um
and it may surprise to you to to um hear
like for the most of of its history the
Greeks didn't didn't consider themselves
as one people as one culture as one
nation right so that's why the Greeks
never were able to expand that
far right the Athenians the Spartans
were too busy fighting each other to
deal with with others ultimately it was
the Macedonians to conquer Persia, not
the Greeks.
Okay. Um, this is Italian war of
independence. The Italians rebelled
against the AustriaHungary Empire. Okay.
So, the Austria Hungary Empire comes
into threat as well. And again, the
AustriaHungary Empire, it is a
multithnic state. And the nation and the
different ethnicities in the Austria
Hungary Empire, it is clamoring for
independence.
um the Austri Empire there are lots of
Slavs Slavic people within it and they
are calling to Russia for aid. Okay. And
as you know what starts World War I is
assassination of the here to the Austria
Hungary Empire by a Syrian nationalist
in Sahaval right which brings Austria
Hungary Empire into direct conflict with
Russia which then brings in um Britain
and Russia sorry which brings in Britain
and Germany as well and this creates
World War
I and World War I and World War II are
the deadliest ye wars in human history
by far. Okay. Millions and millions of
people are killed after World War I. You
have the rise of extreme nationalism. Uh
which which is what we call fascism.
Okay. Fascism is just the extreme
version of nationalism. This is Mus
Mousolini who was the founder of fascism
and he explains fascism in this way. We
have created our myth. The myth is a
faith, a passion. It is not necessary
for it to be reality. It is a reality in
the sense that it is a stimulus is hope.
It's faith. It's courage. Our myth is
the nation. Our n our myth is the
greatness of the nation. And to this
myth, this greatness which we want to
translate into a total reality we sub we
subate everything else. Okay. Fasm is a
belief
that the nation the people is in is in a
eternal struggle of the fittest. Okay.
It must defeat other nations if it is to
survive. And even though the nation
looks weak, as long as we stick
together, as long as we believe in each
other, as long as we fight together, we
will be invincible. Okay? And this is
the again this is the romantic
nationalism driving both um Italy as
well as of of course Germany. Um this is
a fascist Philippo Marini and he says we
want to glorify war the only cure for
the world and militarism patriotism and
the beautiful ideas which kill. Okay. So
for fascists war is a good thing because
war automatically unites people together
in the final struggle
um for survival. And war is a process
that you can use to remode
people into the most extreme
nationalists. Okay, does that make
sense? Um, this of course leads to the
rise of Hitler in Germany um as well as
Stalin in the Soviet Union. Okay, so
we're going to focus in Tyler Stalin
next class. I mean, he's that important
of a historical figure. Okay. So, but
um um after World War II, people started
to look at the
tremendous carnage catastrophe of what
what had happened. Okay, this is Hannah
and she wrote a book called the origins
of totalitarianism. It is a fantastic
book by the way. Um it's it's one of my
favorite books. Definitely the
considered the greatest work of
political philosophy in the 20th
century. Okay, it's it's basically
required reading in university when you
go there. And in it, she basically tries
to explain why the Holocaust happened.
Uh why World War II happened. Um how was
it possible for the Nazis to rise in
power in Germany and for the communist
to rise in power in the Soviet Union.
Okay. And what she explains is this. The
ideal subject of Sultarian rule is not
the convinced Nazi or the dedicated
communist but people for whom the
distinction between fact and fiction
true and false no longer exists. So what
she believes what she argues is that
these regimes systematically eroded
people's capacity to judge for
themselves. Okay. Basically these
regimes destroyed the idea of the
individual and that's what allowed for
totalitarianism to arise in these um
states. Okay, this is Carl Pauper. And
Carl Pauper is like her henna rant, uh,
a European Jew who escaped the the
devastation of the Holocaust and the war
and they both went to America. And he
wrote a very famous book called The Open
Society. Okay. And he argues the open
society is is one in which men have
learned to be some extent critical of
taboss and to base decisions on
authority of their own intelligence. So
what he argues is for peace to happen,
for peace to ultimately um thrive in
this world, we need to we need to
celebrate the individual rather than the
nation. Also, we need to be skeptical of
these grand theories of human history.
Okay, we need we need to avoid Hegel. We
definitely want need to avoid Marx, but
also Plato. These are the three baddies
of the western tradition. Plato, Hegel,
and Marx because they're
anti-democratic, they're
anti-individual, but also they have a
theological view of history of things
that's moving towards the final end. Um,
that is a megalomaniacal view to
understand the world. We need to be
skeptical. Okay, we need to
incrementally make change society.
And so what he's really doing is he is
proposing that Anglo-American
civilization is far superior, far more
scientific, far more advanced than both
Russian and German civilization. Okay,
that's what he's really doing. And
that's and that's why Carl Parker's open
society has become an intelligent basis
for the American Empire. Okay. So very
quickly let's let's understand the
difference between World War II and the
and the Pax Americana which is the age
we live in today. World War II was about
the nation state. Okay. The rise of
nationalism and fascism. The Pax
Americana is about the international
rules-based order. Okay. The United
Nations, human
rights, the generic convention, all
these things. Okay. It's it's it's what
they call the rulesbased international
order. Another difference is World War
II was about mercantalism. Okay,
mercantalism is basically you have your
own separate trading zone and you only
trade within this zone. So that creates
an incentive for Britain, for Germany,
for France to go and conquer other
colonies in order to facilitate uh their
own industrial production. Okay, America
is saying no guys, let's just focus on
global free trade. Let's have everyone
trade together and if everyone tries
together there is going to be
peace. War II is a separation of the
unit of will right? That's what fascism
is the unit of will. We as a people if
we come together we will be this invis
invincible inevitable historical force
that will overwhelm the whole world. Uh
today we just focus on consumerism. Just
go buy things guys. Okay? Buy things be
happy. We're good. All right. So uh this
is this is introduction. We will discuss
this when we finish some when we finish
the class with the American Empire.
Okay, that's next Thursday. All right,
but that is
um that okay so
um copper's open society rubric in the
American empire creates these new trends
in society that really weren't there
before. Okay, so for example, identity
politics. Okay, identity
politics is one such trend. Um, identity
politics is really the celebration of
individual helplessness. Okay, we're all
individuals and we all require the state
to help
us. Okay, so the state is fun
fundamentally about protecting the
vulnerable including uh minorities,
including women, including immigrants.
Okay, does that make sense? That's what
identity politics is
really. You also
have mass immigration. Okay. And this
again um uh and and mass immigration is
celebrated in America and in European
nations right now. And historically this
was not true. Okay. They maybe they had
immigration but it was more of an
academic need and there's a lot of
political push back against mass
immigration. Today it's celebrated.
Okay. But when you do that, when you
have identity politics and mass
immigration together, that ultimately
creates a conservative
um push back, which is what we're seeing
today. Okay. So, the Trump era, which
started only a few months ago, there's
mass there's deportation deportations
going on. Uh it's possible that you guys
will not be allowed to go United States.
Um you know, all this is possible
because of this conservative push back.
All right. So in other
words, even though um the nation state
created a lot of problems that the Pax
American is trying to resolve by
focusing on more individual
rights, the focus on individual rights
is going to create more problems that
may also allow for a return of
nationalism in the future. And I think
that's a very strong possibility that
we'll discuss at the end of the course
on Thursday. Okay. All right. So that's
it. Okay. And again, what's really
important for us to remember is that
this is all just set up for the next two
classes which will end the uh course.
All right. So this is all just
background information for for you guys.
But was anything
unclear about
today? Anything you guys are not clear
about? Any questions? What is the
difference between the nationalism and
the cult?
Oh. Uh, what's the difference between
nationalism and um a cult? Um, so
there's really little difference between
nationalism and religion, but a cult is
something that we mean um it's much more
like limited, much more small and it
requires rituals as well. Okay. But but
I I think you're right. I think like you
can make the argument that nationalism
it is a form of religion. Definitely.
Great. Okay. Does that make sense? Thank
you. Any any more
questions?
Okay. Okay. Great. So, um next class we
will do the the commerce revolution, the
Soviet Union, and the rise of salin.
Okay.